small formula racing cars and cheering
students come together at the formula
student in Germany 111 teams from
universities all over the world met at
hockenheim this year but winning isn't
everything here one student says being
successful at the end of the season is
obviously a worthwhile goal and that's
also important for motivating the team
and helping you to feel enthusiastic
about the next season but what he likes
is the whole atmosphere of the formula
student events you get to talk with the
other teams and discuss various
technical issues if he has a problem he
loves to go to all the other teams we
always find someone who can help him out
so he demanded an team Indian I'm but
t-rex cotton the events are not
primarily about racing the cars have all
been built by the students a huge jury
made up of representatives from the
automotive industry judges the results
looking at technical application
functionality and practicality you
remember Stephanie says there are top
teams here who work very professionally
some of the technology is high-end where
you ask yourself how they managed it but
there are also teams with very basic
designs and they still get their car
running there too it's fascinating to
see how they know all the ins and outs
of their car vidimo since Otto anger
ball tomm the vehicles are really put
through their paces one of the trials
involves an acceleration test
car handling exercises on a wet circuit
also show how good the designs are in
practice the formulas student is very
much about teamwork but some team one
student says the team doesn't just build
a car it's more like setting up a mini
business every year his team is composed
of around 60 people we also have to take
care of marketing and organizational
matters then there's project management
as a complex project that they have here
especially with the marketing and
liaison with sponsors you know and you
don't spend malkovich one's own ins of
idaho between tests the students keep
working on the cars there's always room
for improvement yeah Philip Gottlieb
says the students are working on
technology of the future that could
later be sold his team has built an
electric racing car he believes they'll
play an important role in a mobility
because they're helping to get young
engineers familiar with the technology
and he and his team members will
probably be the engineers who will later
build these cars the ingenuity the el
distrito a shiny phone dead leading
lights in the automotive industry take a
similar view and have come here to look
for potential employees
love you Oh swaggins Martin wasiq says
there are engine specialists here
mechanical engineers all the IT jobs are
represented Business and Economics all
the kind of people that Volkswagen needs
VW also sponsored several teams
sponsoring here involves more than just
financial help it's about sharing
expertise Tim a sponsor Mackay st slur
says the sponsors work closely with the
team at the start of a season during the
design phase they try to get together
with their sponsors the sponsors also
offer a lot of support during the
production phase making sure the parts
the students design can be produced and
that the ideas from the sponsor are
incorporated early on in the process one
fish on the fugu Murphy he didn't dash
one's own i'm at i'm drinkin the
automotive industry also puts up a
number of prizes Mercedes awarded a
prize for the best electric car singling
out the engineers who could well be the
ones to build the emissions-free car of
the future
you